hi everybody welcome to best of buzz
beef No welcome to the beef of buzz feed
all right hi I'm Jen I'm Ricky
welcome to the best Busby's let's start
the show oh my god
yeah this is Daisy do you eat soup at
the tubs holy Sh
you can do it
keeping Aurelia this was a great one
that was maybe the best stuff yeah the
best of Busbee you can even say oh you
just said I did so this is a show where
we like to hang out and we watch videos
from the past month maybe we hang out
with a producer maybe we have some fun
maybe we do whatever the hell we want
which is true because we can do whatever
we want
we release a ton of videos every week
and naturally we get a lot of feedback
from viewers viewers like you yeah you
don't think we read those comments we do
picking up what you're putting down kind
of like this okay cool that in mind it's
time for comment hunt it's time for
commenting commenting first this first
video is eight slightly odd things every
cat person who's done comment for this
video comes to us from Maury may move a
some of these names we might butcher a
little bit so just let's let us know we
do care about you your names or comment
is I play with my cat's armpits because
they're like flaps and sometime I just
burned my face in their fur that you
what what is an armpit if their body is
like this they look cute little arm clip
do you think cats get Bo 11 faces you
make one drunk and it is from someone
named riddle skittle also they got 0 up
votes no one cared about what video
skittle had to say but we do I'm only 11
I don't care still funny do I think she
was trying to say dough
which is a slang way of saying though
but she's 11 and you know 11 year olds I
don't actually I was really good at
spelling and I was loved all right
people try secret Starbucks drinks this
is a little comment exchange we have
from a you
name the next great thing and it
responds by Jen Cardona and the first
comment is what's the daddy's name who's
never had banana bread and the second
comment is Ricky have you never had
banana bread never had banana bread and
I'm never gonna have banana bread banana
is so good and like maybe a little bit
of like pecan look on home and get any
story I click hello this is time that
people try Burger King whopper Ito's
made hoe left us an instruction I think
that this is a map to a treasure people
are really putting actual effort into
these comments but I'm happy about it
everyone holida numbers step to hit ctrl
+ f step 3 press 9 step 4 enjoy
Oh that is that is not cool that's not
that is so wait what grade would you
give this comment just like a bee
that was some comment aren't in fun kind
of disappointed a John Glasscock didn't
show
hey John Glasscock if you're out here
will you just comment on this video give
us a shout out right you gambling man
Saenz
what it's time for over/under what
oh yeah Oh where there's a game where
yeah okay it's a drinking gum but guess
what we're gonna be responsible Jen and
we're gonna drink apple juice instead of
alcohol so it's a game but it's not fun
one it is fun because you know how much
sugar is in this 33 grams of sugar no no
we're gonna watch how many sexual
Pokemon innuendos can you catch in this
song every time you catch one we're
gonna take a shot of apple juice and
ring that Bell
I'm gonna guess 15 17 all right let's do
this
I know it sounds far-fetched but take a
chain see I'm seeking your star you
should stop jittering with that
electabuzz okay Holly worlds with Holly
I tell it's got tons of experience they
want to be a trail with Mario with
Mirage tavataa grassroot massager yeah I
wanna have a better idea
okay so there was like 12 fish sexual
pokemons any windows this is about 12
ish more than I ever thought I'd hear
and I drink a lot of apple juice hey
that was fun whoa someone's wasted off
of apple juice and it goes let's get out
of here and find someone warrant let's
go outside and try to find a producer to
talk oh my god these hiccups
Jen you're about to trip over like a
light second Oh should we jump on the
elevator now Oh
felt it I felt it it was good keeping
did not like that this is good really
this is really freaky yeah I can feel
the praise upon your breakfast and God
do you want to be on the best of
BuzzFeed right now so you are one of the
best of BuzzFeed
oh it's jumping hey y'all welcome Sarah
Ruben to our house where Ricky and I
definitely live we have Sarah Ruben with
us and she made an awesome viral video
this month called can you solve this
murder that's true well let's watch the
video I just want to say I'm really
proud of the video I did do the makeup
myself and I really don't know how to do
like a special effects makeup so it
doesn't look great it's sure it's not
professional great but you know what I
put in the effort and that's what
matters
let's roll the clip
oh wow that's really yeah oh oh don't be
scared you did this makeup yes very fast
oh that could be that little bit under
propia darling I need your help to find
out who killed me I just cannot remember
Eliza me more like it does with me yeah
there are only four people I can think
of who could have wanted to kill me more
options more options you got to look for
clues so awesome job are you gonna make
are you gonna make more of these are
what I'm working on one right now nothin
can you give us any information yeah
give us a clue thank you my little tease
a rare item goes missing
is it a sock no so uh you're one of like
the BuzzFeed oh geez right that's true
over here when both of us started as a
little baby yeah he's in many years
before that what was BuzzFeed like in
the in the incubation days our meeting
room was just a dining table that we had
in the center of the little area our
boss would just come around and play
little songs on his guitar yeah it was
really fun and now there's like hundreds
of employees as opposed to like ten so
as many people know we do tons of stuff
here at BuzzFeed and one of the cool
things that we do is mithi and they make
fun little DIY projects that make your
life better and we have something even
better than nifty we have Caroline from
nifty Oh
nifty beds Oh get in here oh never see
what's up so tell us a little about
Missy how does it start Wendy what do
you love about it right now we're doing
a lot of like DIY crafts like time
saving money saving things you can do
with the stuff in your home that makes
your life easier what's been the MIT
project that's helped you out the most
in your life recently the drill scrubber
I've actually cleaned my entire
was like this rubber diamond alright
well let's do a nifty video
take it away Internet washer machine
screw soap dispenser brush oh cool
these are all the things we need ya to
make a soap scrubber is that literally
it holy crows you know how they clean
like big floors and hallways those like
scrubber things like I think well I was
on jury duty I saw something cleaning
the floors and I was like oh that's like
that's like really cool because you just
have to push the thing along what if you
could make that like a really small
scale he used your brain yeah so is that
was that a real toilet though that was a
real toy did you just go and clean a
random person's car tire by the way I
did accurately yeah you have some stuff
to clean so let's get to it
mix it with the mixer I knew that was
gonna happen
caroline is feet this has been awesome
hey really had to say your inventions
are nifty we have a lot of fun here on
this show we want to say thank you to
Caroline and Sarah for all their help
throughout a comment if you want me to
force Ricky to eat banana bread next
time we hang out and a shout out to john
Glasscock says john glass y'all go find
out Buzzbee